so one of the things I'm curious how how
did you guys decide on the title was it
almost something else it was marketing I
came up with that the market we actually
didn't know we were just calling it
Shazam 2 uh and then marketing was like
yeah how about this title it's like well
that's actually pretty cool you know uh
I've had you know in the past it's
always tricky it's like with Annabelle
creation that took a lot of of working
like because originally it was just
Annabelle 2 which I was fine with and
then they had like Annabelle begins and
I was like that's like Batman Begins
can't do that it took quite a while but
here that was like their first thing
like how about Fury of the Gods
sounds pretty cool speaking of Annabelle
um there's a there's a few Easter eggs
in this movie that people should look
out for
um uh can you sort of Point people in
the right direction on some yeah they're
kind of a quiet all over I mean that's
the scene with Annabelle in it has quite
a lot of them there's both sort of
plushies of different characters from DC
and there's even like hidden in the
there's like an alphabet poster behind
them there with little you know you have
staro in there and some lesser known
characters and then I have also like
references to old Italian horror
directors like Mario Bava and Lucio
fulchi and uh even like very personal
references to like the schools I went to
as a kids that you know just people in
young shipping Sweden will go like oh
yeah I know what that is
so this is a lot of it uh are there
other scenes that have things that
people should look out for
well I'm I'm in the movie
you can't miss you yeah no no that was
fun too you know first time I'm having
my face in a movie usually it's just my
voice or like my creature performer or
something like that I laughed when I saw
you on screen
um one of the things about this movie is
you like the first movie you get you
push a little bit in terms of like the
horror or the violence if you will
um how much does DC or the MPAA sort of
say to you do we have to go this far or
like what are those discussions like
um no it's a little bit because I mean
even with the studio I mean you're the
studio consists of several people so
sometimes you have you know some people
go like yeah go for it go go for your
horror Roots While others go like hey
um but it's uh you know I I think I have
a pretty good grasp of what you can get
away with in like a PG-13 movie where
this kind of like that that works for
families as well uh but I'm often a bit
surprised
about what people react to like in this
one there's a teacher that dies who dies
off screen but a lot of people have
reacted quite strongly to that and I
think that's because of Jack's
performance in that because he really
you you see the anguish anguish and like
the how much it affects him so I guess
that's why people reacted to that I also
think it's the actor playing that role
that you don't want to see death well
people just expect that person is going
to be okay yeah that was actually the
point of of that casting of like we
should cast someone would be like oh
it's that guy so you expect him to be
around and then he's not so there's a
big part of this movie has to do with uh
uh well not a big part but you managed
to bring another DC actor uh
specifically I'm talking about Gaul and
Wonder Woman into this movie how much
debate was it on how did that happen and
how because it's a key plot point in the
movie yeah no it was there from the
beginning I mean the funny thing was
like in the first movie you know we were
going to have Henry show up as Superman
uh and then
you know when we were shooting that
scene they were like well Henry's not
going to make it on this day you know so
we'll shoot it with a stand-in and then
you know we'll have to pick up his
coverage later on it's like okay so we
shot it like that and then the Henry
thing fell apart and we couldn't do it
so we had to just use the stand-in
footage and that's why it ends you know
before you see his face so for this one
it's like yeah Wonder Woman was in the
script and I was like it's not really
going to happen I mean it makes sense
because of the mythology and the Greek
gods and everything but it's like I
don't believe it's gonna happen and then
uh when we were shooting that scene or
the majority of it uh it was the same
thing or like oh you're gonna have to
shoot with a stand-in and then we'll
pick her pieces up because she's not
gonna make it here to Atlanta at this
time it's like
sure yeah so that's when I'm starting to
think okay so when we don't get her how
do we solve it because it's such a big
it we have to have it in the movie so I
was like okay we need some other God
then I guess can we like have Helen's
character actually survive it's like oh
it's gonna be so lame if she shows up
but that was sort of like my plan B uh
but then it actually happened and we
were actually able to shoot with her
which made me very happy because I mean
we we poke fun at the Headless Cameo you
know in this movie and we could not have
done that if she didn't actually show up
at the end I think because people would
have just been so pissed off when it
happened I was like they are not doing
this again and then but there was a
payoff so I was like oh this yeah
because even yeah when she does actually
show up the you know the first shot we
framed it like that but pretty quickly
so no no look she's here don't leave the
theater don't don't get angry so the
film is too after the credit scenes yeah
the first one feels like it was written
by James Gunn was it
no uh
it was actually supposed to be other
characters uh but then right before uh
we were about to shoot it that fell
apart we couldn't use those characters
uh and I was like but we built the whole
set and everything and you know that
that gas station and everything was was
totally built and I was like yeah I
loved the set and we had the time I was
like can we do something here come on we
can just tear it down and then Peter
saffron
who produced this movie also produced a
peacemaker uh so he made some calls and
made that happen I wish I was very
thankful for I obviously have to ask you
um what was the original plan they were
characters
who are in the Justice Society which
would make more sense when you see the
scene yes but so because we didn't
change much about the scene so can I ask
when did you film those after the credit
scenes was it pre the whole change of DC
like oh yeah yeah no it was way before
all that stuff uh so I don't think
yeah that was yeah
um and with the second scene that
obviously is a Shazam three possibility
um how did you decide on that scene well
more than uh Shazam 3 thing it was
actually you know Mr mind and Savannah
was going to be in this movie uh because
they it was we originally we were like
oh well it's part of Mr mine's bigger
plan to bring the goddesses to enable
them to come to Earth
um because he wanted them to like fight
Shazam
um but it was just too much movie you
know like because even without it the
movies two hours and 10 minutes long so
we had to cut it but it was also like
well people are gonna be like well what
happened with the worm guy from the
first one like you have to
show that so I'm glad that we at least
got to have this little scene to just
show that oh no he's still out there we
haven't forgot about him he's he's
working on something you know so I don't
know obviously and I'm sure you don't
know what the future is with Shazam and
DC and everything but I I've heard that
The Flash movie essentially resets a lot
of the DC Universe
um have you spoken to James and Peter
about the possibilities of what could
happen in the future or is it one of
these things where let's see how the
movie does and then we'll make some
conversations yeah what they have said
is I don't know what the full plans are
but uh what they have said is that since
Shazam is sort of its own thing like the
the stories in both these movies haven't
really intersected with the bigger story
uh and they're like well nothing in
Shazam contradicts anything with that
we're doing for the future of DC
so that's good so nothing needed to
change and like you could do more Shazam
I guess but uh we'll see what happens
um I believe you're doing something I
believe I wrote down below at Netflix is
that your next gig possibly uh I have a
few things going on that are pretty
close to to shooting uh I'm I'll go with
whatever
goes first you know because I'm just
eager to make more and especially horror
after having done two Shazam movies in a
row so we'll see it might be below it
might be something else I'm doing with
different studios around town so
see yeah I I've spoken I know a lot of
directors and it's amazing I think
people outside the industry don't
understand that
um that it's literally whatever script
whatever all the lines that comes
together with scheduling and the script
and the studio that says let you have a
green light that's the one you're gonna
go to yeah it's a bit weird because to
me it's like I like to like Focus okay I
know I'm doing this next and then this
or whatever but yeah you have to have a
lot of things going at once because some
things also just never happen you know
like unfortunately
um so yeah you just have to have a lot
of things going and then you'll see what
sticks and what moves first you know
yeah I I wish more people outside of
Hollywood you know like Middle America I
think people think that the director has
more sometimes more control than you
know yeah because of yeah a lot of
things can happen you know it's weird
because sometimes even Studios will buy
something and yeah we want to do it in a
bidding war and everything and then
they'll go just like uh no it doesn't
fit in anymore and and sometimes you can
have like you know regime changes and
things like that as well where the new
guy comes in it's like oh out with
everything old you know
it's a weird business I'm just going to
say sincerely I hope it's a huge hit for
you I really thank you so much